[Music]
Charlamagne king of the franks emperor
in western europe in arson he's
everywhere Charlemagne in gold in stone
as a marionette as a coin as gingerbread
often is always popular with tourists
the old town is small and comfortably
slow-paced with its secluded squares and
many fountains but now in the
anniversary year of Charmaine's death
special exhibitions are an extra
attraction valuable exhibit items come
from London and Paris the Vatican
Austria and the Netherlands miraculously
they've survived for 1,200 years to tell
their stories today like the tassel o
chalice it was commissioned by the
Bavarian Duke Castle Oh on the occasion
of his marriage to the daughter of a
Lombard King for Charlemagne there was a
clear breach of loyalty the Lombards
were his enemies so he lured castle oh
into a trap and condemned him to death
he also wanted to show royal clemency
and had the death sentence commuted to
life long confinement in a monastery
Costello and his entire family were
divided among various cloisters in the
Frankish realm and with that Charlemagne
simply wiped out tassel O's family there
were no descendants in contrast his own
family flourished Charlemagne Knight
five times had many mistresses and at
least 18 children it said that about 2%
of Europeans can claim their direct
descendants of the Emperor Charlemagne
and his folding throne were always
traveling that's how he reigned over the
many peoples he'd conquered from the
North Sea to the Mediterranean he was
king for 46 years in only two of which
he didn't go to war
his weapons were the secret of his
success Charlemagne had an exceptionally
powerful army for the time the cavalry
evolved as a special branch of the
military that could be decisive in
battle his army was comparatively
well-equipped complete with body armor
and the weapons the Frankish Kingdom
produced were prized because they were
extremely hard and durable
douwe have untied by todd griffith even
when the anniversary exhibitions closed
at the end of september they'll still be
plenty of Charlemagne in after me
there's the town hall for example today
people marry in the same place
the King once celebrated his feasts you
can trace Charlene's footsteps with or
without a guided tour in Aachen the
Imperial seal in the cobblestones points
you to all the important places they
include the Cathedral
Charmaine had its foundation stone laid
in the year 796 it was a huge structure
for its time in 1978 it became the first
German monument to be listed as a UNESCO
World Heritage Site many German kings
were crowned in this church they went up
the same steps Charlemagne had ascended
they sat on the same throne
each sat on
it's still surprising in its simplicity
but for Charlemagne the marble slabs had
immense value they came from Jerusalem
the cradle of Christianity books from
the early Middle Ages are also of
enduring value Charlemagne assembled the
most important scholars of his time at
his court although he himself couldn't
write he reformed and unified
calligraphy introducing the script
called Carolingian minuscule until then
had only been capital letters archons
international newspaper Museum shows how
under Charlemagne lowercase letters as
we know them today were introduced
Charles the great liked it small for
good reason the widest variety of
dialects were spoken new languages
surfaced the beginnings of German and
French for example and to standardize
them it was important to have a
standardized system of writing books
have handed down the knowledge of
feasting and dining at Charlemagne's
court the aolong karolina regularly
invites people to historical banquets
even 1,200 years ago music was part of
them there was fruit vegetables game and
plenty of beer and wine banquets
followed a strict ritual in which of
course the Emperor and his family ate
first and when the Emperor Charlemagne
had put down his knife and belched
loudly then the lower ranks the nobility
could begin as a dad and so it continued
down the hierarchy that's a good thing
not all the traditions are still kept up
today but with pate and fresh salad
we can still revel in a modern version
of the good old days
[Music]
you